Khloe Kardashian packs on the PDA after
defending interracial relationships as
soon-to-be sister-in-law blac chyna
reveals her pregnancy weight gain and
Kendall Jenner opens up about a scary
health crisis while Kim continues to
keep a low profile Khloe Kardashian got
her x-men on for Halloweekend channeling
Halle Berry's character storm
hello monies boyfriend Cleveland
Cavaliers player Tristan Thompson was
Black Panther and the couple spent their
night grinding and makin out
this comes after Chloe took to her
official app to defend interracial
relationships quote like who the eff
cares anymore it's so crazy because
we're all human beings capable of love
so why does skin color have anything to
do with it
meanwhile soon-to-be sister-in-law blac
Chyna showed off her baby bump on a
snapchat and her weight gain China says
she's packed on more than 70 pounds so
far but remember that still under her
way to gain gold like no lie my goal is
to gain 100 pounds this pregnancy imma
tear it up and then I'm a snap back then
there's kendall Jenner who will reveal a
health crisis on the next all-new
Keeping Up with the Kardashians the
sleep paralysis is like really getting
to me nothing can move you have a week
in Paris in the lawn and then London
I can't travel that much well you're
already booked I'm like scared I'm
freaking out and Kim is continuing to
fly under the radar following that Paris
robbery
she will reportedly not attend an event
in New York City later this month
honoring her late father her mom and
sisters are still expected to attend the
annual angel ball